The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
HONG LIU: OK, so let me
first summarize what we
did at the end of last lecture.
So we can see that
the Rindler space
can be separated
from the right column
into into four
different patches.
In particular, there's a left
patch and the right patch,
and this is a constant
row slice in the Rindler.
So what we showed is that
the Minkowski vacuum,
the standards, the
vacuum we defined,
the Minkowski
quantum field theory,
can be written as
an entangled state,
and we express it in terms of
the Hilbert space of the left
and the right patch.
So this n sum over all possible
in the [INAUDIBLE] state.
So this n and n are eigen
vectors, eigen values,
and eigen vectors of the
Rindler Hamiltonian, which
we called HR.
And so this, similarly,
is an L. So an R
means the eigen vector
in the right patch
and an L is the eigen
vector for the left patch.
And now when you trace out,
for example, the left patch,
suppose you're only
interested in the physics
in the right patch when you
trace out the left patch,
then you find the sum of density
matrix for the right patch.
[? Under ?] the [? sum ?] of the
density matrix is the partition
function for the full Rindler
minus 2 pi h and so you
conclude that the
temperature is 1 over 2 pi.
So that's what we did at
the end of last lecture.
So there are several
key elements here.
So the first key element is
that the Minkowski [? ground ?]
state turned out to
be a particular kind
of entangled state between
the left and the right patch.
And then you get the
[? sum ?] of density matrix
when you have a Lorenz
above the left patch.
So these are two of
the basic elements.
So any questions on this?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
left patch.
Is there any physical
meaning to the left patch?
HONG LIU: It's the same physical
meaning to the right patch.
For the observer in the
right patch, of course,
you don't see the left
patch, and so that's
why you get the [? sum ?] of
density-- yeah, that's why
you have to integrate them out.
Yeah, they play a very
important physical role.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
observable [INAUDIBLE]
HONG LIU: This is just
pure Minkowski space.
Yeah, this is just
This is Minkowski space.
So this kind observer can
only observe the right patch,
so to this kind of
observer then you
must integrate out all the
physics in the left patch.
So that's why they
see a similar physics.
Yeah, so this is just
a physical explanation
why this is similar physics.
AUDIENCE: Why do we need to
introduce a harmonic oscillator
during [INAUDIBLE]
HR can be anything?
I forgot the reason why we
introduced harmonic oscillator.
HONG LIU: Oh, I just
gave you a simple example
to explain this kind of
physics using a simple example.
just in case you're not
familiar with this kind physics
I gave you a simple example
to build up your intuition.
the reason we considered
the harmonic oscillator
is not an important reason.
Say if you [? quantize ?]
the scalar field theory-- so
any theory on this space,
say if you [? quantize ?]
a free quantum field theory,
that just reduce the harmonic
oscillator.
So the harmonic
oscillator in fact
have the exact same physics as
general quantum field theory
you consider.
Any other questions?
AUDIENCE: May I
repeat my question?
The right patch, the
[INAUDIBLE] patch,
corresponds to the exterior
of the black hole, right?
HONG LIU: In the
black hole problem,
the counterpart
of the right patch
is exterior over the black hole.
That's right.
AUDIENCE: So the upper
patch is the interior?
HONG LIU: That's right.
AUDIENCE: So what are
the kind of [INAUDIBLE]?
HONG LIU: The left patch is
[INAUDIBLE] asymptotical region
over the black hole, which
is also outside the horizon.
So the extended black hole
has two asymptotical regions.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So is there any
kind of [INAUDIBLE] way
with the left patch [INAUDIBLE]?
HONG LIU: Yeah, as I said.
Yeah, I'm going to talk
about this a little bit.
I'm going to talk about
black hole in a little bit.
Any other questions?
Good?
So let me make some
further remarks.
The first is that this Minkowski
vacuum-- this entangled
state between the left
and the right-- is
invariant under the
[? axim-- ?] Or maybe
I should say-- let
me just say it.
It's invariant under
HR R minus HR left.
By invariant under this
I mean-- so this state
is [INAUDIBLE] by this, and this
invariant under any translation
generated by this combination.
I'm not using very
precise English,
but I think you
understand what I mean.
Anyway, so this you can
see immediately from there.
I just [INAUDIBLE] this
harmonic oscillator example,
and if you act this on that--
so this R means Rindler,
and this R means the right
patch and left patch.
So act this on that
state, then they just get
an E because of the minus sign.
They just canceled.
And so this minus
sign is related.
What I said last time is that
you can think of the left patch
half the time running
over the direction.
By time I mean this
[INAUDIBLE], OK?
So what this operator
gener-- it does
is the generator flow--
there's a generate flow in eta.
So the eta goes
running to so this
goes running to [? comes ?]
in the low surface.
And the flow in the right
quadrant is going up,
but in the left quadrant
it should go down
so the time should be moving
[? normally ?] direction,
and that's what this
minus sign means.
And then this
transformation, we'll
leave this state invariant.
And you [? graph ?]
the same thing
like we did before for
the harmonic oscillator.
Any questions on this?
So you can immediately
see from that equation
this operator
[INAUDIBLE] that state.
So this can also
be-- so do you have
any problems saying that
the HR generated translation
along this?
Is this clear to you?
AUDIENCE: So the [INAUDIBLE],
the time [INAUDIBLE]
are opposite.
Does it mean that any other
physical is the opposite time
and [? changing weight ?]?
HONG LIU: It doesn't
matter what you mean.
It doesn't matter how you
interplay, physically.
Right now, I'm talking about
the mathematical statement.
I want to first understand
So this mathematical
statement has two layers.
Let me write explicitly.
This means i HR R minus HL, HR
left acting on 0N with reach
any eta this is invariant.
This is invariant.
This, you can just
see directly from that
the fact this
[INAUDIBLE] that state.
And then that means
that this thing
leaves this thing invariant.
Under the action of
this guy, this operator,
from the point of view of the
red patch because one thing,
you generate the
translation in the eta
because HR is the
[INAUDIBLE] for the eta,
so this just generates
the translation in eta,
which leaves rho invariant.
And this slice I'm showing here
is the constant, the rho slice,
so that means this generates
a translation along that arrow
direction, moving
to positive time.
And this minus sign means
that, in the left patch--
because [INAUDIBLE]
transformation
we are moving
[? in the only ?] direction.
And then that operation, we
will leave this state invariant.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So one question.
So sometimes people have
this interpretation--
I'm not sure if this picture is
correct-- but in the black hole
picture, we interpret
the bottom thing
as being some sort of white
hole, which sort of spews out
things.
So if we reverse time, then does
it sort of become a black hole
again because now it's--
HONG LIU: No, no.
We are talking about
completely different things.
Here, I'm just talking about--
in the left and in the right
you can choose whatever
time direction you want.
I'm just making a
statement that said,
if I make this
kind of operation--
do a time translation in
the positive time direction,
but in the opposite time
direction in the left--
that particular operation
leaves the this state invariant.
For physical applications
you can choose whatever time
direction you want.
You can choose whatever
time direction you want.
And this is a
mathematical statement
saying this particular operator
leaves this state invariant,
and this particular
operator half
of the interpretation of
generate opposite time
translation in the left
and the right patch.
So this is an
algebraic statement,
but this can also be
seen geometrically.
This can also be
So if you work out the relation
between the Minkowski's
coordinates and the
Rindler coordinates,
you can actually
immediately just see
is that, geometrically,
eta translation is a boost.
in x, T. So what that does,
it just generates a boost.
So if this is not
immediately clear to you,
just go back and try to look at
a translation between the two
coordinates.
Then you will see
it immediately.
So in other words, this HR
actually generates a boost.
This Hamiltonian essentially
generates a boost.
This Rindler Hamiltonian
One second.
Let me finish.
So, clearly, by definition,
the Minkowski vacuum
is invariant on the boost.
So this statement is
essentially the statement
that this thing is
invariant on the boost.
And then you can see
this negative sign.
Then you can see the
negative sign from the fact
that if you make
a Lorenz boost--
and this is the trajectory
of the Lorenz boost,
and it acts off the direction
in the left and in the right.
So that's why there's
a negative sign here.
So this negative sign
goes [? bonds, ?]
so the geometric
statement that when
you make a Lorentz boost
in the Minkowski plane,
and the action on the
left and on the right
is in the opposite
direction, so the same boost
will take a point here to there,
but we'll take a point here
to here.
And you can check yourself.
And this translates into
an algebraic statement--
just become this statement.
And this statement is
the same-- that this
is invariant on the boost.
So this is the first remark.
And the second remark is that,
if we expand the field phi
R in the right patch in terms
of a complete set of modes,
just ask, what do
you normally do when
you do canonical [INAUDIBLE]?
In the right patch,
say-- so this
defines a [INAUDIBLE]
and the creation
operators for the theory
in the right patch.
And, similarly, you can
do it in the left patch.
And then you can show, just
based on that relation--
just based on that
relation, you can show--
so let's consider the
freescale [? of ?] [? field ?]
[? series ?] so you
can show that this--
just as the harmonic oscillator
example we discussed before--
and this Minkowski state can
be written as a [? squeezed ?]
state in terms of
[? their ?] vacuum.
And now you have to take the
product of all possible modes,
and only the j is the
frequency for each mode.
So this is a precise analog
of the harmonic oscillator
example, just because
each set of modes
gives you a harmonic oscillator.
So you just take the
[INAUDIBLE] product
of all these
harmonic oscillators,
and then you have this relation.
Also, very similarly,
the usual Minkowski
creation and the relation
operators are related.
So this ajr, ajl by Bogoliubov
transformations, just
as the harmonic
oscillator example.
So we are allowed to write
this transformation explicitly.
But he's saying here,
just direct generalize
of the harmonic
oscillator example
because the field
series is just a bunch
of harmonic oscillators.
A field series is just a
bunch of harmonic oscillators.
Any questions
regarding this point?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So, just to
check-- so the right only
affects the right patch and
its identity everywhere else.
HONG LIU: Sure.
AUDIENCE: So that the
combination leaves the bottom
and the top portion just fixed.
So the combination
leaves the bottom
and the top quarter fixed?
HONG LIU: You don't get back
to the-- yeah, when we-- yeah,
so this is-- so this
operation itself does not
direct-- so this operation
itself does not direct access
to the top and bottom portion.
And this is a
[? trajectoral ?] for them.
So if you have a
point there, just
take them to the
[? hyperbolic ?] trajectory.
So we're not taking to there.
AUDIENCE: Right.
And the top and the bottom
are just-- it's [INAUDIBLE].
So it keeps them fixed?
HONG LIU: No.
When you define
the Hilbert space,
you only define for
the left and the right
because they don't
define Hilbert space.
The Hilbert space defines
the given time slice,
so that only includes
the left and the right.
And those particles run
into future evolution,
and that evolution is
not controlled by them
because they only take you
along the hyperbolic trajectory.
Any other questions?
Good?
So the third remark is
that all of the discussions
generalizes in complete parallel
to Schwarzschild space time
In particular, we said
before, the Schwarzschild time
have the falling space
time causal structure.
You have a whole-- so this
is your regional region
outside the horizon,
but then you
can extend this part of the
space time into four regions.
In particular, you
have two-- again,
you have R and L-- two
asymptotical regions.
So this way the R
goes to infinity,
and similarly this way,
also, R goes infinity.
So, again, in this
[INAUDIBLE] vacuum state,
which it can be defined
from going to create
the [? signature ?] and the
[? compact ?] [INAUDIBLE] phi
this tau.
Again, corresponding
to an entangled state
between the left and the right.
And if you ignore the
left, again, you'll
get a similar state
from the right.
So the story's
completely in parallel.
It's what we discussed before.
The only different thing
is the technicalities
that, of course, in the
specific metric are different.
The specific metric
are different.
And in particular,
this [INAUDIBLE] vacuum
can be obtained by doing
Euclidean paths integral.
Again, will be the half space,
so this is the tau direction.
Again, you do the half
space, and the times S2.
It's the same thing exactly
as we did for the Rindler.
You do the half
space and when you're
interpreting in terms of this
tau [? foliation ?], which
is angle, then you get
this entangled state.
You get this entangled state.
So any questions on this?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Just to clarify.
So this entangled
state is really
nothing more than a
mathematical trick to help us?
Or should I think
about it physically?
HONG LIU: No, this is a fact.
This is not a
mathematical trick.
If we're grabbing that
case, the Minkowski vacuum
is entangled state.
If you write it in terms of
the Hilbert space over the left
and the right patch.
This is a mathematical fact.
This is not a
mathematical trick.
AUDIENCE: Well in the sense
that I'm perfectly also allowed,
I can create something
which, in my patch,
gives me the same
description-- if I just
think of a perfectly
thermal state,
and I don't even have to
think about that being
en entangled with anything.
Is that also OK?
HONG LIU: Oh, sure.
Yeah, but I'm just
telling you-- if you
are observer in the
right patch, of course
you will never see
anything on the left patch.
I'm just giving you a
physical explanation.
Where does that
physically-- where
does that thermal
[? nature ?] come from?
AUDIENCE: Sure, OK.
Yeah.
I just wanted to clarify that.
AUDIENCE: Is this
Minkowski [INAUDIBLE]
defined in the upper patch?
HONG LIU: Sorry?
Yeah.
So you're talking
about this upper patch?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
HONG LIU: So the stories are
[? falling. ?] In the standard
[? QFT, ?] in the
Minkowski spacetime,
you define whatever your states
at [INAUDIBLE] equal to 0,
then you move this time.
Then, of course, that
will include this part.
And then the standard
Minkowski time evolution,
in terms of capital T,
will include this part.
But if you do the
Rindler time evolution,
then you will not
involve that part.
Yeah.
Is that what you are asking?
AUDIENCE: So it's not
defined in the upper patch?
HONG LIU: Hmm?
AUDIENCE: So it's not
defined in upper patch?
HONG LIU: No.
It's not-- it just does not
access those informations,
because the time translation
is always like this.
The time translation
will always--
will never take you there.
You have to ask, what is
your time translation?
So in quantum mechanics,
you define an initial state
and then you have
a [? tone ?] intake
you wove into future time.
And in-- then,
depend on which time
you use, then cover different
regions of the Minkowski
spacetime.
If you use the standard
Minkowski time,
capital T, then that
will cover everything.
If you only use
the Rindler time,
then that only covers this
region or this region.
Any other questions?
Good.
The fourth remark.
So now, let me call this--
so this is r and l and then
this f.
OK?
So let me call this region f.
So this story, experienced
perfectly in this Schwarzschild
spacetime, why an
observer in infinity
will see, say,
thermal radiation.
But actually, this
does not apply
to the real-life black holes,
because the black hole formed
by gravitational collapse
only have the right
and the future region.
You don't have the left region.
OK?
So this discussion
does not apply.
OK?
This discussion does not apply.
But this is only one of the ways
to derive that the black hole
have a finite temperature.
In fact, the Hawkings
original derivation,
just by considering
scalar field,
quantizing scalar field alone,
in the right patch,
and he already
did deduce the thermal nature.
So even though this
particular discussion
does not apply,
all our conclusion,
all our conclusion does apply.
OK?
Our conclusion does
apply, including
the finite
temperature, et cetera.
OK?
So now, to interpret, where
does this temperature come from?
And later we will say, actually,
the black hole not only
have a temperature, it can
satisfy all the thermodynamics.
So in this case,
to interpret where
this temperature come from
is physically more intricate.
OK?
So I will not try to do it now.
But later, when we talk
about the duality, and then
that will be a better place
to go back to this question.
And then we can ask the precise
difference between these two
cases.
Between the case which
you have all patches,
and the case which
you only have two
pat-- only have two regions.
And that they are, actually,
physically fundamentally
different.
Physically
fundamentally different.
But the reason those
conclusion applies
is because the
temperature, in fact,
is a state that can be
made by the local observer.
For local observer,
outside the horizon,
he's not going to tell the
difference between this metric
and the exac-- and the
almost identical metric
in outside horizon.
Outside the horizon,
Schwarzschild metric
is a perfect one.
So locally, he will not
tell any difference.
So that's why the local
observer should always
see the temperature.
If you see it in one case, you
will see it in the other case.
OK?
But the underlying physics will
turn out to be very different.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: How are we
defining temperature here?
Are we defining it by means of
energy, like we do [INAUDIBLE]?
HONG LIU: Yeah.
Yeah.
Yeah, here, we define it in
terms of the density matrix.
AUDIENCE: Oh, it's
defined by that equation?
HONG LIU: Right.
Yeah.
So the density matrix-- so if
you have a density matrix like
this, which z is traced explain
[? to ?] [? matters ?] beta h,
then you say the temperature
is one over beta.
So that's how we
define temperature
in quantum statistical physics.
Yeah.
So this defines a
canonical example for you.
And this beta is the
temperature, the [INAUDIBLE]
temperature.
OK.
So any questions on this?
I hope not, because I want to
discuss this later, not now.
AUDIENCE: Sir?
HONG LIU: Yes?
AUDIENCE: If we hold up
a thermometer like this,
should we get some
different temperature
than if we let it fall?
It's accelerated right now.
Can this has been measured?
HONG LIU: No.
Because it's too
low, the temperature.
Right.
Yeah.
Yeah, because our
temperature would
be much bigger than
this temperature
you are able to-- yeah.
Just the fluctuation
of air in this room
will create fluctuations in
temperature which much higher
than that kind of temperature.
AUDIENCE: In space,
can be a vacuum.
HONG LIU: In the
space, you also have
to do very precise measurement.
It's-- yeah, you
have to calculate it.
h bar is very small.
AUDIENCE: Divide by the mass.
HONG LIU: Yes?
AUDIENCE: To-- constructing
on that same question.
So the same thermometer that
is being held in position.
So if I observe it
while sitting down here,
so I'm accelerating with it,
I'm like the Rindler observer,
and I would see it at a
certain temperature, right?
Although it's very
small, so we haven't been
able to measure everything.
But if I am,
instead, free-falling
while the thermometer
is being held in place,
would I then not see-- would I
then not measure a temperature?
Would I measure temperature?
HONG LIU: Yeah.
Yeah.
You wouldn't be able
to see a temperature.
Yeah.
Free-falling.
Although won't see--
AUDIENCE: So the
thermometer is being
held-- so the thermometer
is accelerating?
HONG LIU: No.
Thermometer is
also free-falling.
No, if you free-fall, the
thermometer also free-fall.
AUDIENCE: No, no, I mean--
he holds the thermometer,
and he is sitting in
his chair, but I'm
the one who measures the
reading on the thermometer,
and I'm free-falling.
HONG LIU: Yeah, that's
an intricate experiment.
Then we have to analyze that.
So the photon from
his thermometer
then will somehow go into your
eyes, and you will analyze it.
Then whatever is the
reading on his thermometer,
you will see it.
Yeah.
No, you're not doing
any measurement.
You just see the reading
on his thermometer.
If his thermometer
has a temperature,
then you will see a temperature.
AUDIENCE: Right.
HONG LIU: Yeah, you are not
doing a measurement yourself.
AUDIENCE: So, OK.
So now, bringing it back to
non-gravitational physics,
flat spacetime.
I'm a [? neutral ?] observer,
and I see a thermometer
accelerating by me.
I would therefore see it as
reading a certain temperature?
The thermometer itself
isn't a measurement.
You need to have something
to measure yourself.
HONG LIU: Yeah, it's
not [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: Sorry?
HONG LIU: No.
No, the thermometer--
whatever thermometer
is doing, what you are doing--
you just read the thermometer.
And it has nothing to do
whether the thermometer has
a temperature.
Thermometer maybe
have a temperature
due to some other reason.
Whether you have--
what you could do
is just read that thing.
Yeah.
HONG LIU: OK.
So let me continue.
OK.
So now, we found a black
hole has a temperature.
So then, you only need to take
a very small leap of faith.
Saying, if this guy
has a temperature,
then it should satisfy
thermodynamics.
OK?
Then we say, this must
obey thermodynamics.
OK?
Also obeys thermodynamics.
Black hole.
And then, you
immediately deduce there
should be entropy,
because now you
can just apply the first law.
For example, we have the
thermodynamical relation dSdE
should be 1 over t.
OK?
Say, if we think of
t as a function of e,
then by integrating
this equation,
we should deduce what is the
entropy of the black hole.
So remember the t of the black
hole is 1 over-- remember,
the t of the black hole,
the t of the black hole.
Yeah, let me do it here.
t b h of the black
hole is h bar kappa
divided by 2 pi, which is the
h bar divided by 8 pi g n times
m.
So this would be just
8 pi g n times m h bar.
Of course, you identify
the mass of the black hole
with its [? image. ?]
So you identify them.
So now, you can
just integrate this.
You can just now become
a trivial exercise.
Then you find s e
is equal to 4 pi
g n e square divided by h bar.
And the plus
integration constant.
OK?
And this integration
constant we can
say to be zero, because
if the black hole have
zero mass, of course
there's nothing there.
And so then, we just
have this formula.
So this formula can be written
a little bit more geometrically.
So also remember, the black
hole-- the Schwarzschild radius
is 2 g n m.
OK?
So this can be written a little
bit in the geometric way.
So this can be written in terms
of s 4 pi r s square divided
by 4 h bar g n.
OK?
Now g n goes to the
downstairs, because the r s
contain two powers of g n.
So this is given by the horizon
area of the black hole, divided
by 4 h bar g n.
OK?
So now we conclude--
we conclude just
a bit-- let's connect these
two formulas together.
The temperature
of the black hole
is h bar times the surface
gravity divided by 2 pi.
And the entropy of a black hole
is the area of the black hole,
area of the horizon of the black
hole, divided by 4 h bar g m.
So as I said before,
for the black hole,
there are two very important
geometric quantities.
One is kappa, surface gravity.
The other is the horizon area.
And then they enter in a very--
in a nice and simple way,
into the temperature
and the horizon--
the entropy of a black hole.
And let me call
this equation one.
This is an important equation.
So let me just note one thing.
This temperature
is rather funny,
if you look at that
formula, because the mass is
in the downstairs.
Say, if you increase the mass,
then the temperature actually
decrease.
This is actually opposite
to your everyday experience.
OK?
Because when we
increase the mass,
the black hole
temperature decreases.
OK?
If you calculate the,
say, specific heat,
the specific heat is
smaller than zero.
OK.
So we will later
see this is actually
an artifact of a black hole in
asymptotically flat spacetime.
So here, we're considering black
holes in asymptotically flat
spacetime.
If you think about black
holes, say, in the spacetime
like [INAUDIBLE] space, and
then actually, the temperature
will go up with the mass.
As in the ordinary story.
OK?
So this is just
the third remark.
So another third remark is that
this equation, these equations
tend not to be universal.
So we derive it to the simplest
Schwarzschild black hole,
but actually, those relations
apply to all black holes
have been discovered.
Just apply to every black hole.
OK?
So now let me talk about
general black holes.
So we are mostly just
making some statements.
Because most of the
statement I make here,
they are highly nontrivial.
And each statement
may take one lecture
to prove, or even more, so I
will not really prove them.
I just [? coat ?] them.
And I can also not
prove it on the spot.
So first is something
called the no-hair theorem.
So no-hair theorem says that
stationary-- stationary's
a key word-- and asymptotically
flat-- this is also
a key word-- black hole
is fully characterized
by the first, mass.
Second, angular momentum.
Third, conserved gauge charges.
OK?
So the Schwarzschild black hole
we talked about corresponding
to a special case, which
angular momentum is zero,
and the conserved charge--
yeah, conserved charge--
for example, the
electric charge.
For example, electric charge.
OK?
And so-- yeah, so
let me just give
some-- so typically
we denote mass by m,
and angular momentum by j,
and the electric charge by q.
So the Schwarzschild
black hole goes one
into the j equal to zero,
and the q equal to zero,
but more general black holes
you can have both j and the q.
So for our-- in
string theory, there
can be many, many
different gauge fields.
So in string theory,
actually there
are many, many
different charges.
So black holes,
in string theory,
can have many, many more
charges than, say, just
in the standard model.
Just in the standard model.
Yeah.
Just for all those black holes,
this equation one still holds.
OK?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So in
proving this theorem,
we're going to kind of start
off with a certain definition
of what is a black hole and
what isn't a black hole.
So what is the key
feature that defines it?
Because there's lots of metrics.
And some of them
are characterized
by only these three things,
and some are not, and--
HONG LIU: You must
have an event horizon.
AUDIENCE: Just the
presence of some horizon?
HONG LIU: Yeah.
So event horizon.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: OK.
But in Rindler we
have an event horizon.
HONG LIU: Hmm?
AUDIENCE: In Rindler we
have an event horizon that's
not a black hole [INAUDIBLE].
HONG LIU: That's true.
You should at least have object.
You should have some mass.
You should have
some quantum number.
AUDIENCE: I could
be accelerating next
to the [INAUDIBLE].
HONG LIU: So, no,
no, no, no, no.
Rindler is called
observer horizon.
It's observer-dependent horizon.
And in the black hole, it's not.
AUDIENCE: So you cannot go to
any frame where there is no
[INAUDIBLE].
What if you are free-falling?
HONG LIU: Hmm?
AUDIENCE: What if
you are free-falling?
HONG LIU: No no no.
Yeah, what I'm just saying that
the-- here, here the horizon,
you can-- different observers
have different horizons.
AUDIENCE: So you can [INAUDIBLE]
the horizon out of the picture?
HONG LIU: So here, the
horizon is arbitrary.
It depends on your observer.
Even though I draw here,
but-- this does not
have to cross the origin.
This can be anywhere.
It's anywhere.
Just here, there's no
[? generating ?] a horizon.
AUDIENCE: But if I'm
free-falling into a black hole,
I also don't have
a horizon, right?
HONG LIU: No.
AUDIENCE: Because I'm causally
connected [INAUDIBLE].
HONG LIU: That's
true, but independent
of that, there's the
spacetime structure,
there's a horizon there.
In the spacetime structure
of the Minkowski space,
there's no horizon.
In order to talk about
[INAUDIBLE] horizon,
you have to talk about
specific observer
to have specific motion.
Yeah, I write down the
Schwarzschild metric.
And the different
[INAUDIBLE] in the way.
There is already
an event horizon.
AUDIENCE: How do you
write down a metric
in a [INAUDIBLE] invariant way?
HONG LIU: No, I'm just saying
the motion of the horizon
is a [INAUDIBLE] variant.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Yeah.
But if I'm in a frame
that's free-falling,
then I don't see
a horizon, right?
Isn't that [INAUDIBLE] which
transported me to a frame
where there is no horizon?
HONG LIU: Maybe let me say this.
If this can make you
a little bit happier.
To a [? symptotic ?]
observer, there's a horizon.
There's a different
[INAUDIBLE] invariant horizon.
AUDIENCE: OK.
HONG LIU: Yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, if you don't want to
fall into the black hole,
for those people,
there's a horizon.
[LAUGHTER]
And the difference from here,
if you fall through the horizon,
nothing happens.
So this no-hair
theorem is remarkable,
because it says if you
have a star which collapsed
to form a black hole,
in this process,
all the features of
the star were lost.
Because black hole only are
characterized by those numbers.
OK?
But star, you can
characterize in many,
many other different ways.
But the black hole, essentially,
don't have any features.
So this is called
no-hair theorem.
All features.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: What if
I add something
like [INAUDIBLE] scalar field
or other field into that
[INAUDIBLE].
[INAUDIBLE] theorem?
HONG LIU: Yeah.
Yeah.
The story is a little
bit more complicated.
Let's try to not go into that.
There's something called
a secondary [INAUDIBLE],
et cetera.
Yeah.
It can.
It can, but this is
refers to Einstein.
But if you go to the frame
of Einstein plus-- Einstein
plus some meta-field, and then
this as a statement is true.
Any other questions?
OK.
So now-- so
historically, of course,
people did not discover
the temperature first.
So historically, people first
have the no-hair theorem.
So it seems like black hole
is completely featureless.
OK?
It's a very boring object
that don't have any feature.
And then, people discovered
the so-called four laws
of black hole mechanics.
For general black holes-- for
general stationary black holes,
again.
So the zeroth law-- again,
we just [? coat ?] them.
[INAUDIBLE] is gravity.
Kappa is constant
over the horizon.
The first law is
that if you change
the mass of the black
hole a little bit-- OK,
imagine you put something, throw
something into a black hole,
you change the mass of the
black hole a little bit,
then you find such a relation.
a is the area of the horizon
So J is the angle of momentum.
And omega is the angle of
where you can see the horizon.
So if you have angle of
momentum on the black hole,
we would be rotating.
So omega is the
angle of frequency.
And fie is the
electric potential.
So if you have a charge,
than the back hole, all
the current electric
fields, this
is electric potential
at the horizon.
And you always, in
this old notation,
you normalize the electric
potential to infinity to be 0.
So this is the first law.
It just say if you change
mass of a black hole,
and change some
angle of momentum
and change some charge then
to the first order they
satisfy this relation.
They satisfy this relation.
So this is just purely
mechanics, a classical of gr.
This is pure, classical gr.
And then there's a second law,
which is also classical gr,
is that horizon area
never decreases.
And the third law, says
the surface gravity--
let me just call it kappa.
This kappa surface gravity over
black hole cannot be reduced
to 0 in the finite
number of steps.
AUDIENCE: What do you
mean by number of steps?
HONG LIU: Find the
number of procedures.
AUDIENCE: Like?
HONG LIU: Say if
each time you throw
a particle to a black hole,
this is called a step.
AUDIENCE: Sure.
OK.
Thermometer, like [INAUDIBLE].
HONG LIU: That's right.
Yeah.
This is called a step.
Right.
OK.
So all of these are
classical statement.
And so this tells
the second law.
For example, if you throw
something to a black hole,
the black area will increase.
So if you collide
the two black holes,
and then if you collide
two black holes,
they will merge into
a bigger black hole.
And this bigger
black hole, the area
will be larger than the sum of
the area of two black holes--
than the area of
two black holes.
Yeah.
So of course this law
just-- these four laws
then become immediately
just like the four laws
of thermodynamics.
You make this
identification of one.
This identification of
one-- so if it's one,
this just becomes the four
laws of thermodynamics.
Yeah.
Thermodynamics.
The four laws of thermodynamics.
In particular, the first law, if
you substitute the copper and A
by the temperature under
the entropy, than this just
becomes the standard, the
first law, in particular.
The first law, it's just
dm, sdt, tds plus omega
dj plus 5 dq.
So this is really the first
law of thermodynamics.
So historically, these
four laws of mechanics
actually was discovered
before Hawkings radiation.
So first they discovered
this black hole law theorem.
And then they discovered
these four laws
of black hole mechanics.
Then they say,
ah, this is really
look like thermodynamics.
And they even patterned
these four laws
to precisely like the four
laws of thermodynamics.
But they could not
imagine the black hole
was a thermodynamic object.
They could not imagine the black
hole was thermodynamic object.
So they were saying, if you
look at the old paper-- there
was a very famous paper by
Bardeen, Carter, and Hawking,
which discuss these four
laws of black hole mechanics.
And they said, this four
laws of black hole mechanics
should actually transcend the
standard of thermodynamics.
The black hole actually
should transcend
all of these, our
traditional physics.
But in 1971 or 1972, a
young graduate student
called Bekenstein, so he was a
graduate student at Princeton.
So he was studying
under a guy called
Wheeler, studied under Wheeler.
And so he was very
uncomfortable with the fact
that if you throw something
into a black hole,
than that thing is gone.
So he was a very
uncomfortable with that.
Because if you throw something
to a black hole, it's gone,
then he concluded that's
really the second law
of thermodynamics.
Because if you throw to a
black hole, that thing is gone,
then the entropy associated
with that thing is gone.
And the black hole
is just black hole,
have this no-hair theorem.
And then you violate the
second law of thermodynamics.
People like Wheeler or Hawking,
they say, ah, this is great.
Black hole transcend
the thermodynamics.
But Bekenstein
was uncomfortable.
He thinks thermodynamics
should transcend black hole.
And then based on the second
law of the black hole,
then he said, so maybe--
so he wrote a series
of papers, a few papers.
I don't remember.
He say, if we think black
hole has entropy proportional
to the area, then the second law
of thermodynamics can be saved.
Because this area
of level decrease,
and if you throw
something to a black hole,
even thought that, the entropy
associated to that guy's lost.
But that area also increased.
The area also increased.
And then you can say it's the
second law of thermodynamics.
Now, he actually proposed
to generalize the second law
of thermodynamics.
So he proposed a
generalized second law.
He said, you take
the total, if you
take the total
entropy of the system
to be that of the black
hole, and then matter
field outside the black
hole, then this ds total
must be non-decreasing.
Of course, now if we accept,
if we take this leap of faith
to really think black hole as
a sum or object, then of course
this generalized
second law has to be
true because the
thermodymaics-- some object.
But when Bekenstein
proposed it, it
was really bizarre
to say in a nice way
because it just sounded
crazy, just outright crazy.
Because how can black
hole have entropy?
Black hole absorb everything.
Just how can it have entropy?
And it just completely
was disregarded by people.
And it was discarded by people.
And anyway, but then
now that he was right,
then of course after Hawking's
discovery of a Hawking
radiation, they become very
natural for the black hole
to have entropy.
And in particular, this
formula, after you determine
that the black hold have
this temperature, after you
fix this pre-factor,
then you can
also, just from the first law,
just from here, just from here,
to fix that pre-factor
of a black hole.
So Bekenstein could
not decide what's
the proportional constant.
But once you get
the temperature,
then this proportional
constant just uniquely
fixed from this equation,
so without using that.
Just using the first
law of mechanics,
then you can immediately
integrate that as entropy.
Anyway--
AUDIENCE: How did
Bekenstein find--
HONG LIU: It's a postulate.
It's a gas.
Yeah.
He just postulate,
if we imagine--
AUDIENCE: He didn't derive it?
HONG LIU: No there's
no way to derive it.
He was just saying,
if you imagine
black hole has entropy
proportion to the area,
than the second law of
thermodynamics can be saved.
And he wants to save the
second law of thermodynamics.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So one question.
So this makes sense classically.
If I have a system of entropy,
I throw them to a black hole.
Entropy is like ignorance.
If I throw ignorance
into the black hole,
maybe there's somehow
the black hole
also becomes more
ignorant or something.
But what does this mean in
terms of quantum mechanics
when I have a pure state?
From quantum
statistical mechanics,
substance the entropy, you
just don't know something
about your state.
And it's your
fault. And it's not
like the black hole should
car if it's your fault
or not or something.
So why does this makes
sense quantum mechanically?
Maybe it doesn't.
HONG LIU: You mean, why does
black law have entropy make
sense quantum mechanically?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
HONG LIU: It's the same thing
as-- this room has entropy.
This room we use quantum
statistical physics.
If you believe black hole is
an ordinary object, then--
AUDIENCE: We only quantum
statistical physics
because we're ignorant,
the full state of--
HONG LIU: Yeah.
For a black hole, we
are also ignorant.
Yeah.
This is actually something
I'm going to talk about now.
Any other questions?
AUDIENCE: I have
something [INAUDIBLE].
So basically, I think it can
be [? a healing ?] experiment.
So where we hear
things of [INAUDIBLE].
There is one unit of entropy,
and it enters black hole.
It increased the energy
of black hole, which
increased the mass
increased the [INAUDIBLE]
of the black hole.
So in this way you can actually
derive the semi-qualitatively
derived out of proportionality.
HONG LIU: Yeah.
To derive with these precise
[? cohortions-- ?] no,
I don't think they derive
the [? cohortion ?],
but I need to check.
I don't think there's
any way to derive
the-- you can, say, put some
bond on the [? cohortions ?].
But you cannot derive
the [? cohortions ?].
I think that argument
would not enable you
to derive the [? cohortions. ?]
Anyway, so let me just
mention a few more things
about black hole.
This is just pure-- actually,
I'm running out of time.
So let me just mention
some paradox or paradoxes
for the black hole.
So we have shown that the
black hole is some object.
So Jordan just asked.
But we know the ordinary
thermodynamics has
statistical physics behind it.
So the immediate
question is actually,
does the black hole
entropy, for example,
have a statistical
interpretation?
So this is one question.
And another question is that,
does black hole actually
respect quantum mechanics?
Does black hole respect
quantum mechanics?
So if black hole entropy have
a statistical interpretation,
then this give you a
very-- so it black hole
have a statistical
interpretation that
means-- so A, if
affirmative, that
implies that each black
hole, even though black hole
at a macroscopic level only is
characterized by these three
things, But macroscopically,
must have internal states.
Or, maybe I should call
it macrostate of order
to the entropy, which is
the A of the black hole area
4h bar e.
So hidden behind
this no-hair theorem
is actually a huge
number of macrostates.
Just like the air
in this room, even
though we describe the
unit temperature, pressure,
and the energy stature, but
given that macroscopic data,
they can be huge
number of macro states.
And then a similar thing should
happen to the black hole.
And in order to see that
the black hole does have,
a statistical
interpretation, then you
have to find so many states
for a black hole and in order
to answer the question
A. So this question
has to be answered
in the affirmative
for many different
type of black holes.
Say in string theory and
also [INAUDIBLE] spacetime,
and they see the spacetime.
Using string theory method or
using this holographic duality,
we will see examples later.
We will see examples later.
So these really confirms
that the black hole is really
a quantum statistical system.
So regarding this question B,
then this long time paradox--
so this A has also been
a paradox for many years,
and was only resolved--
the basic calculations were
able to do only in 1996,
when the [INAUDIBLE],
they did some very special
[? Schwarzschild ?]
black hole, which they counted
this exact number of states.
They counted the exact,
this number of states,
and about for a very
specific type of black hole.
So B is rated to the so-called
Hawkins information paradox,
information loss paradox.
So I will not have time
to go into detail here.
Let me just give you a
very rough version of it.
So you can see the
pure state, could see
the star, a big star
in the pure state.
So we know from gr that a
sufficiently massive star
will eventually always
collapse to form a black hole.
So if we imagine you have a pure
star in the pure state collapse
to form a black hole, and if
quantum mechanics is preserved
throughout the process,
then this black hole
should also be a pure state.
So that means the
black hole should
be just one of all those max
number of possible states.
There should be a pure
state, but only one
of those all possible states.
But then Hawkins had an argument
saying this is impossible.
Because if black hole is
a pure state, then when
black hole evaporates-- so
the black hole evaporates,
eventually the black
hole will be gone.
So the one funny
thing about black hole
is that the temperature
is inverse proportionate
to the mass.
So when the black hole is big,
then the temperature is low,
then the radiation is small.
But when you start radiate,
then the black hole mass
will decrease.
And then the temperature will
be higher than we radiate mole.
So it will be
acceleration process.
And eventually-- presumably
black hole will be gone.
So this kind of semi-classical
argument that we are given
applies only for a
massive black hole
much greater than the planck
mass, only much larger
than a planck mass.
So below planck
mass, what happens?
Nobody knows.
But at least this
radiation statement
should be robust for the
mass much, much larger
than the planck mass.
Now Hawking then say
this is a paradox
because according
to his calculation,
the radiation is simple.
And we know that
the sum of radiation
does not contain
any information.
It cannot contain information
but it's pure state,
because sum or radiation
is information free.
And so the sum of
radiation which come out,
come out until you reach say
the mass of all the planck mass.
And here we reach
the planck mass.
And then before you reach that
mass, because the radiation is
simple, there can be no
information can come out.
And when you reach
that planck mass,
it just becoming possible
for such a huge amount
of internal state to be encoded
in the planck mass object.
So he concluded that the
information must be lost,
and the black hole
must violate mechanics.
So this is a very
heuristic argument.
But I highly suggest,
if you are interested,
to go read his original paper,
which is very beautiful.
Because he was really trying
to think of black hole
as a ordinary quantum
mechanical object.
And the way he was thinking
about it is really very nice.
And actually, it's
not very different
from we are thinking
about black hole
right now, from the
holographic duality.
He was really
thinking that's it's
a quantum mechanical object.
But then he reached
this paradox.
Anyway, so this paradox
had bothered the people
for more than 30 years.
So he discovered the
Hawking radiation in 1974.
I think he proposed
this paradox in 1976.
So for more than
30 years, people
argue with each other
what is going to happen.
It's typically divided
into two camps.
So the gr people, they think
black hole is everything,
quantum mechanics nothing.
And the black hole must be able
to violate quantum mechanics
and will bring us to a new
frontier we never see before.
And the particle, these
people are saying,
a black hole-- oh, we can even
creating the accelerator--
must obey quantum mechanics.
So people would just
argue with each other
and without really setting
the question in a very
convincing way to either camp.
But this holographic
duality, in the context
of holographic duality, then
the black hole [INAUDIBLE]
spacetime, then you
can actually rephrase
this question about the
black hole information laws.
And the holographic
duality strongly
suggests-- I think it's
maybe not really completely
proved-- strongly suggests at
least that the black hole is
just a ordinary quantum
mechanical object.
We are not transcend
the quantum mechanics.
Yeah.
I am really out of time.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So you said the
star is in a pure state.
But how can that be,
because it has a temperature
and it's also thermal system?
So how can you put
it in a pure state?
HONG LIU: No.
Black hole does not have
to be in the thermal state.
No.
I can certainly imagine a star,
which is in the pure state.
In real life, maybe it's
hard to construct them.
But on the paper, I can do it.
[LAUGHTER]
In principle, so how
many atoms in the star?
I don't know.
Maybe 10 to 100?
Now let's imagine there's
10 to the 100 atoms.
AUDIENCE: But it's radiating
all the time though.
Doesn't it entangle with
things and make it not pure?
HONG LIU: Don't worry.
Don't worry.
I can certainly write down
a wave function for 10
to the 100 particles,
which is in the pure state.
And this will be a big object.
And according to the
rule of gr, this thing
will collapse to
form a black hole.
AUDIENCE: What about the
light that it's emitting,
which it has--
HONG LIU: No.
There's no light.
No.
We work with zero
temperature, just pure state.
There's nothing.
AUDIENCE: No temperature?
Zero temperature?
HONG LIU: Yeah.
In principle, I can do that.
AUDIENCE: In that case,
will the black hole
have the temperature,
Hawking temperature?
HONG LIU: Yeah.
The black hole will have
Hawking temperature.
AUDIENCE: But it's still
in it's first state?
HONG LIU: The black hole will
have a Hawking temperature,
will have-- similar,
have entropy,
but will be a pure state.
So this is the essence of
the information paradox.
And then we will be
able to explain it,
why this is so, using
the holographic duality.
AUDIENCE: So as the
star collapses, it
gains a non-zero temperature.
It starts at zero temperature,
and then collapses, and becomes
[INAUDIBLE].
HONG LIU: Yeah.
It can.
Yeah.
It seemingly have a
long zero temperature.
Yeah.
Maybe let's stop here.